fish stock is the base
bring that up to the boil now to take
that broth to another level in with
chopped shallots fresh ginger and a
whole chili seeds and all I actually
quite like it it's spicy
[Music]
adjust
once and into the broth
bring up the ball and let it simmer
Gallagher it's sort of almost like a
softer version of Ginger slightly Milder
you can use galangal paste but I prefer
the fresh stuff the stems
for coriander we'll finish it off with
the
heads and that's what endeared me to the
Southeast Asian style of cooking
across my travels there was there's no
waste in
lime leaves
for me
one of my favorites incredibly pungent
Strong full of flavor very acidic but
gives a really nice Aroma to the broth
just tear them
and now the lemongrass
so the secret here that's where all the
flavor is right at the very end so you
take the back of the knife and you just
bash the lemongrass
it's all that flavor it's going to run
out in seconds that's the base
of the broth down the longer you leave
it the more intense it gets whilst the
broth infuses soak your rice noodles in
boiling water for 10 minutes the last
job before serving the clams
never be scared of cooking shellfish the
most important rule is if they are
slightly opened a millimeter discard it
make sure mussels clams are always tight
cook the clams for just three to five
minutes or until they're all open
bring that up to the boil and this is
where we finish the broth
touch up fish sauce a little sprinkle of
sugar
drain your noodles
into the bowl
added texture
some delicious bean sprouts
get your lime fresh squeeze and lime
juice in beautiful
literally as the stock comes up to the
boil the clams open automatically
so they cook beautifully
the flavor from inside the clam has
enhanced the broth
smell is incredible
the clams cooked finished with fresh
coriander and serve
there you have a perfect lunch it's
hearty delicious robust but served with
some tortillas and a wonderful salsa
it's almost like a complete meal in one
starting with some finely chopped red
onions for my soup let's get some heat
going early these are chipotle so
they're Smoky Rich they don't come with
any warning signal and these are
seriously hot so be adventurous but
beware
nice teaspoon of toasted cumin oregano
dried
now it's not frying off spices the Heat
you see the chilies start swelling up
delicious garlic be quite generous on
the oil because that helps to blow out
the chili right now those onions and
garlic are on fire
we're going to balance the sort of heat
from the Chipotle with sugar turn up the
heat and really start caramelizing that
sugar and the chili gives off the most
amazing aroma
next fry up a tablespoon of tomato puree
add a can of chopped tomatoes
cook kidney beans
and vegetable or chicken stock to cover
there's something quite exciting about
big and bold flavors because in the
restaurants you have to be somewhat
controlled you can't go crazy so cooking
these kind of dishes at home gives me
that kind of release chilies
particularly when they're dried continue
to swell and release their heat as
they're cooked so the longer you cook
your dish the hotter it will be
but it's not as powerful it needs to be
yet and every five six seven eight
minutes that's gonna get stronger hotter
and more delicious
bring it up to the ball and cook that
out for 15 minutes
whilst I allow the chili heat to infuse
I'm going to crack on with quick crunchy
tortilla chips and a fabulously fresh
and spicy tomato salsa known in Mexico
as pico de gallo
start by finely dicing three ripe
tomatoes
one or two deceded fresh jalapeno
peppers
and half a red onion
then chop a good handful of fresh
coriander
add the juice from two limes
salt and pepper
and a drizzle of extra virgin olive oil
for the tortilla chips rub a little
olive oil onto six large shop-bought
wheat wraps
[Music]
sprinkle with smoke paprika and gently
massage in
cut each wrap into triangles and spread
them onto a baking tray
bake for three to four minutes in a
preheated oven 180 degrees until golden
brown and lead to cool
complete my Mexican lunch I need to
finish my deliciously fragrant spicy
soup
the spices there it is absolutely spot
on
now for the cooling down process the
Mexicans are brilliant at building layer
upon layer of flavor with delicious
chilies and spices but they're also
experts at tempering their dishes with
cooling ingredients like avocado sour
cream and cheese that's why you can take
that amount of chili you don't have a
spoon of richness spice all of a sudden
avocados almost like a little fire
blanket over those chillies
to further counter the chilly heat
Mexicans use a rich Tangy crumbly cheese
but I'm sprinkling on Lancashire which
is a Great British substitute
and last but not least cooling fresh
coriander one delicious spicy Mexican
soup serve that with your tortilla chips
and your pico de gallo salsa
a phenomenal blend of textures and
layers and spice and creaminess big bold
and delicious this is a very classic
Mexican style brunch dish bold Kick-Ass
flavors slice the chili seeds in
garlic sliced nice and thinly
tablespoon of olive oil
I'm a big fan of brunches and if you get
it right a great brunch you can see
you're right through to dinner now to
start the sort of spicy fragrant tomato
sauce get your cumin in there
garlic chili roasted cumin red onions
already sounds Mexican
[Music]
once that starts getting really nice and
crispy in with your tomatoes
instead of embarrassed using good canned
tomatoes I do all the time cooking at
home
Now by reducing that you sort of come
down to a delicious paste leave that to
simmer
next canned beans called black beans
these are authentically Mexican but
cannellini beans or chickpeas will work
just fine just rinse them a little bit
of water
that is beautiful turn off the gas and
just let it absorb leaving the dense
beans to luxuriate in the spicy tomato
sauce will allow them to soften and soak
up all the flavor
next oil and season an oven proof dish
for my spicy egg brunch to baking
just get some of that oil
around the outside
take your corn tortillas slice them in
half and then just stick them to the
side
these are a staple in Mexico
take one replace that in the center
get your mix and place that on top of
the tortilla
spread that out nice and smoothly lift
up those little flaps I want that crisp
shell on the outside
now your eggs and cheese get the base of
the egg and just make a little hole in
there and then crack
the egg into the again use a little
point
put your egg in there one
two
three
four five and one in the middle
gently crack and get the egg to sit
inside almost like it's a little dug out
and then one for the center
get a really nice rich delicious strong
Montgomery cheddar I want a grape the
tortilla shell as well so get generous
with it on the top and we'll season that
with these little babies
little chili flakes they're my little
secret weapon and they're going to spice
up that egg
salt a touch of pepper
sit there in the oven to bake for eight
to ten minutes and 180.
[Music]
[Applause]
that smells incredible
it's a little bit of coriander to finish
it off
and that for me is what brunch is all
about let's go
a fantastic fiery brunch to get your
party started spicy Mexican eggs and a
crispy tortilla shell
there's something you can do in the
morning and put it in the oven because
it has to be cooked really really slow
yes I'm gonna dust this in flour it's
amazing how many chefs are using oxtail
on their menus today it's incredible
it's fairly popular it's very cheap as
well it's amazing I used to make it
stretch for like five or six dinners
I've done exactly it's not that bad now
I know why we're also skinny growing up
it wasn't that bad I'm joking come on
you know I'm joking but you see
sometimes we went to the butcherson you
had maybe extra two or three I used to
put in a saucepan and you had lovely
stock for soup what was that spicy soup
really nice
and they used to make a good pot of
scotch broth Scotch broth I remember now
I'll peel a couple cloves of garlic no
I'll show you a quick way of getting
that out get your knife and just wash it
nice
peel them and I'll crush them in the
garnet Crusher thank you all right
oxtail in I'm gonna fry that off and you
can get that nice and brown and we've
all braised it in red wine and sort of
chicken stock before but I'm gonna get
this done with a Chinese influence the
Chinese absolutely love cooking oxtail
you started cooking at home quite early
on right 17 and a half 17 and a half
your mum died quite young very young 26
26 so who taught you how to cook
I think you just learn as you get older
and you learn by your mistakes and then
enjoy it yes I did enjoy it yeah that is
a nice vegetable not a fennel fennel
isn't it they're lovely that's beautiful
yeah a lot of people do use it a lot of
them use it in salads but no one
actually Cooks it you just slice that up
man
now these are nice and brown
and you look lovely yeah put the color
on there
you just sliced up the chili okay just
size it down and keep the seeds in there
because I want some heat as well
star and easy
putting that in there no no one thing
you never used to do was sweat with many
spices there wasn't many Chinese
influences I wasn't very adventurous
with spiciest Pike man no I like ginger
do you I love Ginger especially fresh
yeah coriander seeds a little handful 10
yeah soy sauce
and quite generous in soy sauce four or
five tablespoons that helps give it that
saltiness and a nice dark Rich color on
the vegetables so as it raises the meat
tenderizes quicker I would never do
anything fennel and the chilies and like
because it smells nothing does that
smell nice
and then a little bit of this this is a
a rice wine vinegar yeah
what other tips would you give me in
order to save money on cooking what got
you through that tough time feeding all
six of us and holding two jobs
an hour and a half
then I would think right I'll make a
rice pudding I put an apple pie and for
the same sort of heat use the other
shelf in the oven so you weren't just
watching the pennies in terms of the
produce you also cutting down the gas
bill
wow super nap yes some oxtail back on
top of the vegetables go top that up is
that beef stock yeah no a really nice
chicken stock why are you putting
chicken stock in it because it's quite a
sort of light fragrant way of cooking
oxtail because oxtail itself is quite
Rich yeah chicken Stock's nice and light
just cover it with stock lovely color
isn't it it's a beautiful color
little taste there we go big deep breath
okay Nan
well that's lovely I can taste the
fennel on that is that nice that's
lovely
oh Jesus